我今天要跟你分享的
是一個
我過去
不可能公開的
秘密當沖方法
只要觀察兩個跡象
就有95％的機率
會提前預測到
即將暴跌的股票
這個方法
為什麼今天
我突然決定公開
原因很簡單
雖然它能幫我
每天穩定賺個
3000塊左右
但是我沒辦法
放大這個獲利金額
看完這部影片
你就會知道為什麼
所以說
當我的資產
變多之後
還去用這個方法
反而效率很差
決定把這招
分享給其他需要的人
如果你希望
每天使用一個
勝率超高
速率超快
的當沖方法
每天幫自己
賺個3000塊左右
那這一招
剛好是你要的
這部影片
我會把這兩個跡象
分別是什麼
它們的底層邏輯是什麼
全部講清楚
影片後面
我也會分享
更進階的
獲利放大技巧
記得看到最後
我是小王子
在股市裡打滾20年
靠股票當沖跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
我就不廢話了
直接來帶你看
這兩個跡象
到底是什麼？
第一個跡象
是股價的圖形
我把它叫做
低點 整理 再回低點
當一檔股票
今天已經出現過
一個低點
接下來
股價先上漲一段
然後在一個區間之內
上下震盪
過了一陣子
股價又開始往下
重新逼近
剛剛提到的
今天最低點
這樣的圖形
就是我們要找的
第一個跡象
為什麼這個圖形
這麼重要？
因為它背後
其實藏著
兩群人的心理狀態
而這兩群人
正是等一下
推動股價
暴跌的關鍵力量
第一群人
是在出現低點後
進場買進的當沖客
他們有
各式各樣的原因
認為股價會繼續上漲
可能是認為
股價被低估了
或是反彈出現了
無論是什麼原因
當他們選擇買進
你認為
他們的停損點
會設在哪裡
3秒鐘給你思考一下
最多人會停損的地方
就是今天的最低點
因為當股價
今天再次創新低
就代表這檔股票
真的很弱勢
股票的走勢
明顯不符合
他們預期的上漲
所以當股價
再向下跌破這個低點
他們就會認定
今天看錯了
趕快認賠
賣出股票來停損
避免虧損更多
第二群人
是順勢交易的當沖客
這兩種人的邏輯一樣
只是賺錢的方向
剛好相反
就像剛剛說的
當股價再次創新低
代表這檔股票很弱
他們就會順勢操作
跟著做空股票
所謂的做空
就是賭股價會跌
透過先賣後買
來獲利的方法
這兩群人之中
大多數會事先想好
只要股價
一碰到最低點的
下方第一個價位
他們就會
賣出股票
所以你可以想像
當股價第二次
逼近最低點的價格時
這檔股票
這其實已經埋好了
兩個炸彈
一顆
當沖買進
停損時的賣出力量
另一顆
準備順勢交易
做空股票的力量
這兩股力量
都在等同一個瞬間
同時引爆
而我們要做的事情
就是搶在真正引爆之前
看懂跡象
提早卡好位置
第二個跡象
藏在兩個低點
中間的這段區間裡
你要注意的是
這段時間裡
成交量的大小
為什麼
成交量這麼重要？
因為只要有成交
就代表有人賣出
同時也有人買進
這些買進的人
有很大的部分
就是前面提到的
當沖買進的人
但是同一時間
也是主力
最好出貨的時機
我們先來科普
什麼是主力？
什麼是出貨？
主力指的是
當一個投資人
大量持有某檔股票
而且持有的量
多到可以影響
這檔股票的走勢時
這個投資人
就足以稱作
這檔股票的主力
但是主力
想賣出股票的時候
會遇到一個問題
他持有太多了
要有夠多的人
願意買他的股票
他才能夠賣出去
因此
他會製造一種假象
讓其他人覺得
現在是
買進股票的好時機
我們把這一種
他騙別人買進
自己偷偷賣出的過程
稱為出貨
而兩個低點之間
出現區間上下震盪
很可能就是主力
製造出來的假象
如果主力直接
在下跌的趨勢中
大量賣出股票
但想買的人
卻沒有這麼多
股價就會
瞬間暴跌
主力自己
就賣不到好的價格
所以主力只要製造出
股價反彈的假象
在這個區間
買進的當沖客
就會覺得
這裡就是低點了
股價開始反彈了
當其他人
正在搶著買進股票
主力就默默地
把手上的持股
一張一張
慢慢地賣出去
所以這個區間的
成交量越大
代表什麼？
代表主力出貨
越順利
也代表
有越多的當沖客
在這裡買進
等到股價
真正創新低的那一刻
才會有足夠多的人
停損賣出股票
成為最強的下跌燃料
進一步讓股價跌更深
反過來
如果這段區間
成交量很小
代表根本沒有什麼人
買進股票
就算之後再創新低
停損賣出的數量
也會很少
下跌的力道
當然也會比較小
接下來
就是這部影片的重點了
既然
我們都能提前
預知到下跌
那我們就可以
透過做空來賺錢
也就是透過
先賣後買來當沖獲利
但你千萬要注意
我們要賺的是
順勢交易和
當沖停損
形成的快速下跌
股價向下衝
通常都是
30秒之內的事
等到順勢交易的人
都已經進場了
買進的人都停損完了
股價就有可能
再次進入上下震盪
運氣不好
可能馬上反彈
所以我們要做的事
就是快進快出
當你進場做空後
觀察股價
變化的速度
一旦你發現
下跌的速度變慢了
就要馬上出場了
如果運氣不好
遇到反彈
反彈的速度
還快到你
來不及獲利出場
也請你一定要
馬上停損
尤其是股價
如果馬上漲回到
原本低點上面
不停損
真的會很危險
因為這時候
股價會形成一股
強力的上漲訊號
叫做破底翻
你想想
股價會反彈
一定是有人大量買進
買進的人是誰？
有八成的機率
就是主力
主力也知道
當股價再次創新低
很多剛剛買的人
都會停損
如果他真正的意圖
是看漲想買進
那他只要
故意讓股價破低
就可以低價買進
其他人停損的股票
既然主力
現在是看漲
而且正在努力
買進股票
那這檔股票
就算看起來很弱
也不容易跌
因為只要一跌
一股名為主力的
神秘力量
就會撐著不讓它跌
所以不要跟主力作對
趕快買回股票吧
避免後面
股價真的狂漲
那你虧損的金額
就不止這個數字了
總結來說
這個方法超簡單
而且還超快速
兩個跡象出現
進場做空
下跌速度變慢
無論賺賠
都馬上出場
接下來
我們直接用一個
真實的案例
帶你把兩種跡象
快速看一遍
讓你親眼見證
這套方法
實際上會長什麼樣子
我們來看
7/20的台塑化
一早9點開盤
它就往下狂跌
9：05出現一個低點
80.6
馬上出現反彈
但也沒有超過
今天的最高點
84.3
將近20分鐘
都在高低點之間
上下震盪
我們看一下
下面的柱狀體
也是成交量
第一次反彈的時候
5分鐘之內
就成交了7000多張
後面成交量
漸漸變小
價格也逐漸來到
低點80.6附近
這個區間
成交量粗估
也有4萬多張
超過了目前
一半以上的成交張數
10:25
當股價來到80.6
我們仔細看
當時的成交明細
10:25:08
股價正式創新低
來到80.5
10:25:20
股價已經來到80元
短短的12秒之內
股價跌了0.6元
當你在80.5
成交的瞬間
也跟著做空
賣在80.5點
10秒之後
在80.2
你就馬上買回股票
一張股票
你就賺進了300元
10張股票
你就賺進了3000元
以三折手續費來計算
扣掉交易成本
都還賺1100塊
從看到機會 進場
到獲利入袋
不超過30秒
你可以在一天之內
找到許多這樣的機會
你可以把它想像做
每天上班打卡之外
額外領到的一個小紅包
數目不大
但這個紅包
幾乎可以天天領
你可能想問
只要做得更多
不就賺得更多嗎？
答案是不行
為什麼？
你想想看
在剛剛的案例之中
如果我進場時
一次進場是200張
會發生什麼事
那我就會遇到
剛剛提到的
主力的問題
想買的數量
不一定有這麼多
那我就必須
低價求售
賣在更低的價格
更糟糕的是
我還得在30秒之內
反過來買200張
如果想賣的數量
也沒那麼多
我又要出更高的價格
才能買進股票
最後就是
我買在
很貴的價格
卻用很便宜的價格
賣出股票
這一招
能賺的空間
本來就不多了
如果我不能
在最好的價格進出
很容易賺不到
甚至還虧了錢
也就是說
只要數量太多
這一招就用不了了
想賺更多的話
有另外一個
更好的做法
這是我要分享的
進階做法
部分出場
也就是說
不要一次全部出場
先出一半就好
剩下的另一半
切換到另外一套方法
讓你同時
保護好獲利
再去賺後面
繼續下跌的錢
這一套做法
你就要學會
從股價走勢中
判斷主力當下
想要怎麼做
股價接下來
有機會跌到哪裡？
這些就是我到現在
都還在使用的
當沖7大獲利術
全部都放在我的
線上直播講座裡
點下方資訊欄連結
就可以免費報名
講座裡會分享
買在哪？
賣在哪？
以及如何找到
下跌機率很高的股票
很多新手用了這7招
成功放大獲利
常常一天就能賺到
1萬塊以上
講座名額有限
如果點連結進去
沒看到直播場次
就代表暫時額滿了
當沖其實不危險
它能做到很多事
你可以用今天的
紅包當沖法
每天賺個3000元
也可以使用
講座分享的
7大獲利術
快速累計資產
賺到你第一個千萬
但前提都一樣
有方法的當沖
才叫當沖
沒方法的當沖
只能叫賭博
我是小王子
我們下次見